their legs are broken their limbs are
broken you cut off their legs you cut
off their hands as a doctor I have
nothing to do a time you find a patient
who really you feel this machine still
me young still very active you really
want him to go out to go back to his
feet but they cannot have fallen so you
have to go to the implant suppliers and
beg you request please help me help me
and I fix this patient some cases we had
the fractures are too bad and the
implants are very expensive you're
begging cause lands on deaf ears so much
as you may beg but you find they are
very expensive you can't push it
if you ever stuck if anybody is in
opposition all make a pledge for 10
million you guys
right now I mean a Ugandan hospital
[Music]
it's unbelievable I could get somebody
to donate but I need a most of my
questions are actually fifties and these
were people who are previously normal
when they get this accident disables
them they become incapacitated and they
don't have the whole but he has given
them hope just given them hope
what is more important than having hope
there are many who collector who cannot
even think of what will happen tomorrow
[Music]
in the rims of working you cut off their
legs you cut on their friends as a
doctor complicated
when I get a good Samaritan like insta
son he is coming up Nate
[Music]
you are lonely happiness
just way to go
if his long life and with a heart he
continues
[Music]
I remember her words to you
[Music]
dr. Jamila thank you for saving my leg
so that I can walk again and a massive
thank you for the hard work that you do
do you gain by saving so many lives to
anybody watching this video just
remember that the smallest thing that
might seem like a small thing to you can
be such a big thing to somebody else
so always give back always pay it
forward and much love
you